diciamo che è un periodo un po difficile
perché sta succedendo la catastrofe su
youtube
oggi i ragazzi di parole in argomento
serio che sta affliggendo youtube
in quest'ultimo periodo però per farlo
visto che non parlo mai di cose serie
dobbiamo assumere una parvenza di
persona seria
[Musica]
allora ragazzi oggi vi parlo di una
bellissima cosa che sta succedendo su
youtube
porca eva come son gasato praticamente
youtube ha deciso di introdurre una
nuova modalità è quando si parla di news
sono sempre news positive ma di che cosa
cazzo stiamo parlando
questa nuova modalità di youtube si
chiama modalità con restrizione perché
in questa nuova dalità di youtube non si
possono più dire le parolacce ma
passiamo alla linea al nostro inviato
marco che ci spiega benissimo di cosa si
tratta ciao
siamo qui a parlare tra donare
trascrizione modalità che si è attivata
censura determinati video secondo lei
siamo qui per leggerne posto senza
trasmettiamo siamo contati filiere torna
al summit con una certa però che
separano il video parla non utilizzo
della propria offrono alto probabilmente
il pil in questione non sarà disponibile
la moda in atto alle stazioni
terzo anche se come se ciò dichiara
istruttive sull'educazione sessuale
potrebbero essere inserite nella
modalità con le iscrizioni che probabile
che dialoghi troppo dettagliare il
concernete sesso di grassi sessuali
vengono rimossi a cuccia gliel'ho detto
vuoto valenza aldo mai antartico
pubblica contro video che trattano tutte
le cose brutte che possono concedere
nella vita le guerre le dispute
esplosioni potrebbero non essere
disponibile la modalità prescrizione
4 scena un ruolo pubblico adulto anche
un linguaggio inappropriato contenenti
espressioni volgari come si comporterà
probabilmente discussione del video tra
marco restrizione avete proprio ragione
basta parolaccia è finita ovviamente si
potrà attivare e disattivare quando si
vorrà perché sennò a leivi haters
schifoso è un'ala possa disattivare
volendo stiamo dei fatti non s'attiverà
nessuno perché chi cazzo chi cazzo cazzo
se lo guarderebbe youtube senza seguire
uno che dice parolacce rover legge non
esisterebbe youtube stesso quando su
youtube verrà attivata questa modalità
che si chiama dovevamo restrizione
appunto che è disattivata al momento se
facciamo attiva entriamo in un mondo
magico che adesso vi faccio vedere salva
e youtube si trasforma youtube diventa
automaticamente accessibile ai minorenni
e quali sono i contenuti dei minorenni
vabbè automaticamente quindi youtube
filtra tutti i video che contengono
anche solo una parolaccia anche solo un
riferimento sessuale anche solo una
minaccia e filtra tutto io ti odio nel
mio canale o totalizzato di circa 1.200
86 video quanti video vengono
visualizzati se la modalità di
restrizione è attiva sul mio canale
migliore signori ram famiglie insetto
gigante casa panico friggere action
giulia penna un mese fa tra ingegneri ci
mette anche un botto a caricarle ma che
non li trova il disegno perfetto mi sono
fatto verde video al mese ragazzi un
video almè scarta regali natale in
anticipo con jacopo beh grazie al cazzo
questo video è filtrato di brutto
detto questo gli il signor bellissimo
youtube kagami un attimo youtube
guardami poi mettermi a manetta youtube
dove vive di questi polsi che se prendi
un bambino di sei anni c'era più grossi
vuoi farmi del male fisico ok allora
farmelo bene perché vedi questo lo vedi
questo video fa vige il 7 gb di casate
lo sa perché no cosa cazzo è cosa cazzo
ego la merda
no vai via dal mio cazzo di termino
mania mi fai schifo dei morire il morire
male caro youtube hai appena ascoltato
10 secondi di un mio video che non è
nelle restrizioni e in questo video ci
sono parolacce o mio dio cosa cazzo e
minacce di morte dei morire di morire ma
le invocazioni a satana o il demonio
incastrato in un albero e altre cose
fetide come orgasmi poco evoluti la mia
faccia ripresa da vicino che non è il
massimo di sempre dovrebbe essere
distretto anche quest'anno quindi liuzzi
se vuoi scartavetra mi il fringuello con
questi nuovi aggiornamenti davis
khartoum e trarne lo bene e pubblici che
il canale di famiglie scese a 13
iscritti è una cosa che l'ha detto sul
serio
scusami se ti ho fatto così era un
complimento mio io non credo che youtube
vada veramente ad attuare quello che
stiamo pensando tutti quanti ovvero
questa modalità di iscrizione
obbligatoria perché se così fosse
youtube sarebbe morto morto proprio se
così fosse la home di youtube da un
momento all'altro diventerebbe piena di
gattini e basta nient'altro che era a
youtube del 2004 2005 va bene cioè
torniamo agli albori non parlo per me
personalmente che comunque sia a youtube
è il mio mestiere però io faccio altro 3
youtube faccio anche negli esterni
attività che comunque stanno al di fuori
di youtube ballo specialmente per chi fa
youtube come unico lavoro e queste
persone che non hanno introiti
all'infuori di youtube si ritroverebbero
da un momento all'altro senza avere più
un lavoro e questo perché perché youtube
da un giorno all'altro decide che non va
più bene questa cosa e allora tutto va a
[ __ ] è una cosa sbagliata perché se
youtube
cresce in una certa maniera se un sito
se un qualsiasi cosa si evolve in una
certa maniera e diventa così grande per
chi youtube è uno dei siti più visitati
al mondo ragazzi e oggi è uno dei mi
pare che sia il terzo sito più visitato
al mondo credo che siano google facebook
e youtube non vorrei sbagliare non puoi
fare un cambiamento così radicale non
stanno anche a spiegarvi perché non puoi
fare una cosa del genere sbagliato e
proprio sbagliato e non solo non viene
incontro ai creators che che portano dei
contenuti sulla piattaforma novae contro
nati a te stesso infatti non capisco
come una cosa del genere possa essere
anche solo stata partorita dalla mente
di qualcuno che lavora youtube quindi
detto questo spero vivamente che le cose
si evolvono
migliore perché ovviamente questa
modalità ancora non è attiva è ancora in
beta e ancora si deve vedere però
sarebbe veramente un qualcosa di
devastante distruttivo per youtube
quindi ragazzi vi chiedo scusa per
questo breve blog che ho fatto ci tengo
a precisare che io non sono
c'è questa non era un blog sfogo non
sono incazzato per niente anzi il mio
era solo un appello a youtube stesso
alla fine perché
dobbiamo anche farci sentire noi perché
se no qua succedono cose noi siamo
sempre zitti ma [ __ ] se cercate
più informazioni per quanto riguarda
questo argomento ci sono un sacco di
canali che ne parlano molto meglio di me
che io vi do seri non ne ho mai fatti e
che quindi vanno molto più nel dettaglio
ad esempio quei due su server un sacco
di altra gente che l'ha fatto è quindi
andato a vedere i loro video che magari
vi lascia anche descrizioni ringrazio
valko berlino per la gentile comparsa in
questo video marco lasciate l'ultima
parola farci una bella chiesa per il
video bella ragazzi guardate il sole
prescrivere questo pubblici che il
canale di pochi giri scese a 13 street
il merito va vj